what is top gun you think it's a story
about a bunch of fighter pilots it is a
story about a man's struggle with his
own homosexuality you've got maverick
he's on the edge man he's right on the
[ __ ] line all right and you've got
iceman and all his crew they're gay and
they are they represent the gay man
killing me she's she's heterosexuality
she's saying no no no no go the normal
way right that is what's going on
throughout that whole movie it goes to
her house right all right it looks like
they're gonna have sex you know they're
just kind of sitting back he's taking a
shower and everything they don't have
sticks he gets on the motorcycle drives
away she's like what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] is going on here next thing you see
her she's in the elevator she is dressed
like a god this guy's going towards the
gateway so i got to bring him back i got
to bring him back from the gateway but
the real ending of the
the mix at movie
end all right because he has passed over
into the gateway and iceman has been
trying to get maverick the entire time
finally he's got him all right and what
is the last [ __ ] line that they have
because they're all hugging and kissing
and happy with each other and ice comes
up the maverick and he says you can be
my wingman anytime